remind viewers of the pictures that
we're seeing we believe this is off the
Gaza Coast that 40 km stretch of
Coastline a big ship a big boat on fire
there has been struck by air by an air
strike we're also seeing other enormous
splashes around it as if it is
continuously being targeted we don't
quite know what the target is but we do
believe that is off the Gaza Coast it's
unusual for us to be seeing pictures of
a strike on a vessel in the water so
we're going to be keeping an eye on that
and bringing you more information on
exactly what's going on there as soon as
we get it we just a little earlier
before these extraordinary pictures we
saw other extraordinary pictures which
was a barrage a huge barrage of rockets
being fired from Gaza towards Southern
Israel we were about to go to our
correspondent Charles statford who's in
kafar AAR in southern Israel but just as
we were about to go he had to take cover
from we prese resume the rockets that
were being fired from Gaza so Charles
you're back with us now I'm glad to hear
you're safe and sound talk us through
what
happened well Laura an indication of
just how fragile and tense the situation
is here as you rightly say we are in
kafar AAR one of the towns that the
Israeli military said today they've
taken full control of from from Hamas
however as you say we were about to come
up live for you and seem of us are
panicking here it has to be said um
amongst the Israeli military um many
soldiers running for cover initially um
you can hear outgoing artillery there
but it
transpires that um there was great fear
of a possible infiltration back into Kar
AAR now we can't confirm whether that
happened or not but certainly that was
what was being said by some of the
soldiers here them all taking cover
another Soldier said that the incident
had happened about 4 kilometers down the
road as I say it's a you know an
indication of of just how fragile the
security situation is here at the moment
what the military have said though
earlier today is that although they've
taken control of these towns like kafar
AAR they are fearful that there could
well be Hamas Fighters Palestinian
Fighters that are at large that have
taken cover and are hiding in the fields
and farmland in this area of Southern
Israel so yeah the situation remains
very kind of fluid here um and uh
there's a lot of uh rather nervous
looking
soldiers 5 or 10 minutes ago things have
calmed down a little bit but yes karaz
are um we were in the town this morning
um and scenes of utter Devastation
shocking scenes bodies all over the
place many Hammer Fighters many
civilians both Israeli citizens and we
were told also foreign workers their
bodies were still being removed from the
houses in which they were living
um just terrible to see you know their
lives blown out across these manicured
Lawns these these these places that they
lived in and taken pride in are very
different worlds to the world of course
across the border in Gaza but we're also
taking to the fence where there was a a
wide Gap in it where the hammer Fighters
had come through one of dozens of
breaches so the Israeli military tell us
um they showed us a par Rider as well um
which they said Hamas had used to cross
into Israel so they hadn't even counted
the bodies as I say they didn't even
know how many people had been killed in
kafar AAR what we do know is that up the
road in um another Village called biri
that body count has actually been
completed and according to the military
there were 108 Israelis killed in that
Village alone that amounts to 10% of the
population of of that Village so uh yeah
the situation as they say remains very
fluid despite these announcements from
the Israeli military that they have
taken control fully of this area and
it's it's worth remembering isn't it
that despite these fast uh moving
developments that we keep reporting on
and keeping up with that this is an area
this is a country that's still deeply in
shock still reeling from the aftermath
of those horrific attacks on Saturday
morning by Hamas fighters on large
portions of the population what are
people there saying about
that as you say people are in a state of
of of complete and utter shock and many
are very angry too we we weren't able to
speak to any civilians in kapar razar
because there's nobody there the those
that survived um have obviously left
because their Village is in Ruins but we
were earlier on today in the town of
stot which is around 3 km just Northeast
of the Gaza border another Village
another town sorry that was infiltrated
by Hamas and Palestinian gunman um many
of the villages there many of the people
that live there are still there they
don't want to be evacuated but one man
we spoke to perhaps an indication of the
level of hatred that this attack from
Hamas and and other Palestinian Fighters
has caused he was very candid he said
we're going to kill them all we're going
to take them out they have to be
punished we're going to block their food
cut their electricity stop their power
stop their water we have to do
everything we can to get revenge and to
stop this ever happening again and what
was unclear and I pushed him on this
what was unclear was whether it was
actually Kamas he was talking about or
Palestinians um so as I say it's a
graphic and and terrifying indication of
the level of of fear and hatred that uh
that this has
caused okay Charles thank you very much
for bringing us a very Vivid picture of
the scene there in southern Gaza this
Southern Israel this is Gaza that you
can see now well just off the coast of
Gaza this vessel this boat fully on fire
actually he been burning for quite some
time now it appears to have been struck
by air strikes there just off the coast
of Gaza usual for us to see uh vessels
in the water being targeted by these air
strikes we're more used to seeing the
city itself buildings but a large fire
there on this vessel as Rob Reynolds was
saying that if these boats are becoming
targeted might affect shipping in the
area that's something we'll have to
explore in the coming hours let's bring
you up to speed with the death toll that
we are seeing at this current state it
is at 1,
688 that's 900 Israelis
788 Palestinians but we do expect that
number to be rising we're expecting
updates on that number